[Musica]
un bellissimo paesaggio
secondo me anche uno straordinario
paesaggio lì nel mezzo c'è un'azienda
agricola con il mio lavoro di agronomo
ed enologo mi capita di visitare
letteralmente ogni giorno in giro per il
mondo tantissime aziende agricole
diverse c'è una cosa semplice elementare
che tutte le aziende agricole hanno in
comune è il suolo e c'è qualcosa nel
suolo che da tanti anni a me ha sempre
affascinato e mi ha appassionato e il
fatto che il suolo può letteralmente
avere una memoria è un suolo può essere
divo beh quando parliamo di memoria noi
abbiamo le idee chiare
noi sappiamo cos'è la memoria io so che
mi chiamo adriano questa mattina mi sono
ricordato che dovevo venire al ted per
riconoscerli e sappiamo anche dare una
definizione possiamo definirla come una
funzione psichica di riprodurre nella
mente un'esperienza passata e sappiamo
anche molto banalmente dove andare a
collocare la memoria nel nostro cervello
e è la stessa cosa anche per quanto
riguarda i nostri amici animali
quindi la memoria e nel nostro cervello
dove guarda caso anche se
dell'intelligenza se però cominciamo a
domandarci dov'è il cervello delle
piante dove l'intelligenza delle piante
beh cominciamo ad avere un po di
difficoltà perché penso che nessuno di
voi abbia mai incontrato un cervello in
una pianta non ho incontrato nemmeno io
dall'agronomo per fortuna per rispondere
a questa domanda ci aiutano gli
scienziati che si occupano di
neurobiologia vegetale
ci sono diverse università del mondo che
studiano tutte quelle che sono le
interazioni nella pianta e tra le piante
e ci insegnano che la maggior parte
dell'intelligenza delle piante guarda
caso è collocata nelle radici che stanno
solo è lì che dobbiamo andare a
ricercare tutti quelli che sono i
fenomeni legati alle intelligenze alla
memoria delle piante nel suolo quindi
cominciamo un po ad avvicinarci a questo
suolo il suolo qui sotto questa chiesa
c'è del suolo le mie mani stanno tenendo
in mano un pezzo di suolo però che cos'è
di cosa è fatto solo potremmo scoprire
molto facilmente che un suolo è fatto
per la stragrande maggioranza di una
sostanza inorganica minerale un insieme
molto variabile di sabbia roccia limo
argilla e solamente una piccola parte
che va dall 1 al 5 per cento è fatto di
sostanza organica che sa qualcosa che
noi conosciamo già perché l'abbiamo già
sentita nominare come humus quindi
questa è la parte organica del suolo
all'interno di questa sostanza organica
possiamo invece andare a trovare la
parte viva del suolo e quando parliamo
di un suolo vivo vuol dire che è pieno
di batteri funghi insetti e lombrichi
protozoi quella che è la comunità di un
suolo quindi vedrete un suolo può essere
anche vivo e vivente quando è ricco di
queste simpatiche creature che hanno una
faccia altrettanto simpatica perché se
andiamo a vedere che faccia la comunità
di un suolo hanno queste facce e non
penso che nessuno di voi li abbia mai
incontrati nemmeno camminando oggi
arrivando qui beh perché molto
banalmente lo sappiamo abbiamo bisogno
di un grande di un grande ingrandimento
abbiamo bisogno di un microscopio per
andare a capire come sono fatti e quando
abbiamo un microscopio possiamo scoprire
qualcosa di davvero interessante come
per esempio che in un grammo
di terreno un grammo è qualcosa che sta
tra il mio pollice il mio indice in
questo spazio
possiamo trovare in un grammo solamente
dai 100 ai 1000 milioni di batterie
quasi un milione di funghi e molte altre
creature
quindi non solo è vivo può essere vivo
ai quando è vivo ove a una comunità
particolarmente numerosa e guardate
questa comunità la possiamo anche pesare
se noi prendiamo 10 mila metri quadrati
è qualcosa che assomiglia a un campo da
calcio in quel campo da calcio se
ripetiamo la comunità del suolo ove sono
2.000 kg di batteri sono 6.000 kg di
funghi e e tante altre e e tante altre
entità nematodi radici e quant'altro
quindi un suolo può essere letteralmente
vivo c'è la sostanza organica possiamo
misurare il peso e il numero della
comunità vivente di uno solo
bene abbiamo imparato che esiste la
sostanza organica ma che effetto ha poi
la sostanza organica per capirlo
userò questo esperimento molto semplice
dell'università del maryland però molto
efficaci almeno a me ha molto colpito
dove è stata presa la stessa quantità di
suolo in questi due bicchieri di un
suolo che all'un per cento il 3 per
cento di sostanza organica poca sostanza
organica e tanta sostanza organica
tutto il resto è uguale a prima vista
direi che si somigliano potremmo far
finta di vedere davvero molto poco
la cosa interessante è che se
aggiungiamo la stessa quantità di acqua
in questi due suoni scopriamo questo
scopriamo che dove c'è sostanza organica
il suolo ha capacità di assorbire
tantissima acqua dove c'è poca sostanza
organica il suolo non ha capacità di
assorbire sostanza organica
pensate che la cosa non ci riguarda da
vicino se volete vi spiego cosa
significa festa in maniera molto molto
semplice
questo significano alluvioni
inondazioni frane questo è uno dei
grandi spiega menti dei disastri
ambientali un suolo che non collabora
che non ha sostanza organica crea degli
autentici disastri quindi direi che
forse ci è venuta voglia di capire come
questa sostanza organica entry
nell'agricoltura perché ci sono diversi
modi di fare agricoltura
io ve ne parlo vi parlo di circa tre
modi di fare agricoltura i più i più
famosi c'è un modo che si chiama
agricoltura convenzionale e un integrata
è che non si occupa di sostanza organica
prevede l'uso di sostanze di sintesi che
interferiscono nella quantità nella
qualità di quella comunità vivente che
abbiamo chiamato sostanza organica
quindi erosioni problemi molto molto
elevati
per quanto riguarda il suolo e non
solamente anche per quanto riguarda noi
abbiamo poi l'agricoltura biologica è
un'agricoltura che prevede che non si
usino queste sostanze queste tecniche
che alterano la vita di un suolo
c'è poi l'agricoltura biodinamica che è
quella con la quale io lavoro da diversi
anni e nella quale c'è un autentica
ossessione questa ossessione guarda caso
si chiama sostanza organica usiamo le
migliori tecniche possibile per
prenderci cura della comunità vivente
del suolo perché pensiamo che sia
fondamentale per fare un'ottima
agricoltura vediamo in che modo però
possiamo di nuovo misurare questi tipi
diversi di agricoltura è così vero che
diversi tipi di agricoltura possono
incidere così tanto in un suolo
nell'agricoltura andiamo in svizzera
dove c'è il cibo che ha il più grande
istituto di ricerca per quanto riguarda
i diversi tipi di agricoltura in pochi
metri di differenza di distanza due tipi
di agricoltura la convenzione della
biodinamica vengono messi a confronto
non abbiamo bisogno di essere agronomi e
scienziati per capire che questo suolo
non funziona si compatta perde acqua ci
sono poche piante crescono male
dall'altra parte abbiamo solo che sta
collaborando sta producendo tante piante
si stanno sviluppando bene e guardate
che questa storia si ripete ogni volta
allo stesso modo se andiamo in veneto in
un vigneto se andiamo in sudafrica
qui siamo in veneto vedete un solo che
funziona non solo poroso scuro che
collabora è un suolo con sostanza
organica
ecco allora dov'è la memoria di un suolo
e proprio qui l'hanno scoperta molto più
semplice di quello che pensavate perché
non solo può essere intelligente ma non
ha la coscienza quindi non dimentica mai
è costretto ad avere memoria qual è la
memoria beh lui colleziona tutti gli
effetti dell'attività che l'uomo produce
nei suoi confronti se usiamo un tipo di
agricoltura beh si ricorderà del modo in
cui è stato trattato e se usiamo un
altro tipo di coltura come in questo
caso
beh questa è la memoria di un suolo si
ricorda nel modo in cui è stato trattato
e di conseguenza agisce e vedete che la
cosa ha un impatto molto forte su quello
che sono le piante che poi quotidiano
possiamo comparare anche agricoltura
biologica e agricoltura biodinamica
radici più profonde ramificate una
pianta più sana più salutare quindi
forse possiamo davvero far funzionare un
suolo in un modo diverso di mostro quali
sono le tecniche che usiamo in
agricoltura biodinamica per far
funzionare bene un suolo quindi in che
modo ci occupiamo della sostanza
organica
alcuni esempi
la monocoltura distrugge la sostanza
organica motivo per cui cerchiamo di far
convivere più colture possibili
ovviamente sempre in un modo
economicamente sostenibile qui siamo in
liguria a riva al mare questi vigneti
sono circondati da orti ed a frutteti
quindi la biodiversità la monocultura
non funziona andiamo in montagna
possiamo verificare la stessa cosa siamo
in trentino in un vigneto in mezzo a
vigneto vengono coltivate queste verdure
per aumentare la biodiversità e
aumentare la sostanza organica
cosa ci fanno queste o che in un vigneto
in sardegna e queste o che mangiano
l'erba e rendono inutile il passaggio di
un trattore che in questo caso che al
tester ebbe produrrebbe emissioni e co2
e facendolo rilasciano nel suolo ed
escrementi che di nuovo cibo e sostanza
organica per il suolo per questo è un
esempio di un organismo agricolo che
funziona usiamo dei preparati
biodinamici specifici che anche questi
contribuiscono in modo fondamentale ad
aumentare la quantità e la qualità della
sostanza organica di nuovo la comunità
vivente che abbiamo visto prima del
suolo il compostaggio tanti di voi
magari hanno un piccolo composte da casa
e beh questo è un qualcosa di molto
simile semplicemente molto più grande e
sviluppato in modo più professionale ma
il compostaggio non è altro che un
recupero di tutte quelle sostanze che
vengono prodotti in un'azienda agricola
e non vengono non vengono utilizzate per
la produzione del prodotto vendibile e
quindi in questo modo trattati tutti
questi residui vegetali animali e
riproducono di nuovo del concime che è
di nuovo cibo per la terra
quindi la terra va nutrita e vedete
quanti modi diversi
abbiamo per farlo questo è un altro modo
si chiama sovesci ea modo bellissimo per
incrementare anche la biodiversità di
un'azienda agricola seminiamo delle
specifici essenze botaniche tra i filari
di un vigneto tra i filari di un
frutteto nelle rotazioni è un certo
momento queste le tagliamo e vengono
ridate al suolo come autentico cibo per
la terra è di nuovo per quella comunità
che abbiamo visto prima
agricoltura biodinamica deriva dall
antroposofia dove nome stesso ci dice
che c'è un uomo al centro è un tipo di
agricoltura nella quale ci prendiamo
davvero cura di noi umani nelle
interazioni nelle collaborazioni nella
solidarietà e è un fatto fondamentale
per che caratterizza davvero tanto
questo tipo di agricoltura
come vedete fino ad ora abbiamo parlato
di agricoltura agricoltori agronomia
potreste ancora pensare di non essere
chiamati in causa
in tutto quello che vi sto dicendo forse
la memoria del suolo pensate che sia una
cosa lontana da voi che non vi interessi
vediamo se riesco a convincermi un po di
più
questo è un pane lo conosciamo è un
chilo di pane
vi siete mai posti la domanda di quanta
terra e necessaria per coltivare la
farina occorrente per fabbricare per
produrre questo pane sono circa 9 metri
quadrati è una superficie che la vedete
sta attorno a me con un pane al centro
quando allora compriamo un pane che la
cui farina derivata dall agricoltura
biodinamica
noi ci rendiamo responsabili della
salute di quel suolo quindi una cosa che
ci riguarda tutti da molto molto vicino
vedete come la consapevolezza di un
gesto alimentare si connetta subito con
il lavoro dell'agricoltore
entriamo anche noi in un grande cerchio
ai quali siamo responsabili
beh siamo a lucca terra di olio e di
pane e potremmo immaginare che tutti qui
dentro che siamo 450 ci volessimo fare
una bella fetta una fetta di pane con
l'olio
beh se misurassimo e terreno necessario
per produrre l'olio il pane per queste
450 fetonte con un semplicissimo gesto
salveremmo e ricominceremo a far
funzionare o un suolo di 90 metri
quadrati un appartamento intero e
potremmo continuare con tantissimi
esempi un bel piatto di pasta con un
bicchiere di vino una singola azione ci
permetterebbe di salvare quasi un metro
quadrato di suolo quindi vedete come la
responsabilità di ognuno di noi comincia
ad avvicinarsi alla terra anche se non
ci muoviamo da qui allora cominciamo a
pensare un po il grande
a pensare che magari cinque persone per
un anno intero
decidono di alimentarsi con prodotti
provenienti dall'agricoltura che
dinamica e potremmo scoprire qualcosa di
interessante
potremmo salvare una superficie di suolo
di circa 10 mila metri quadrati di nuovo
il campo di calcio di prima
guardatelo è ritornato e se ci piace di
più questa è la superficie che più o
meno copre il pavimento del duomo di
firenze 5 persone semplicemente in un
anno
ora di che superficie enorme possono
salvare di suolo un suolo che quindi
collabora un suolo che non si erode non
solo che assorbe acqua non solo che
tutela tutta quella che è la comunità
diventa del suolo come mangiando
prodotti provenienti da un'agricoltura
attenta che in questo caso di chiama
agricoltura biodinamica
ecco allora che possiamo ritornare
all'inizio del nostro viaggio
questa è un'azienda agricola di mille
ettari non è una piccola azienda
agricola
quindi ora è un po il tempo delle good
news e quello che vorrei darvi è perché
sono delle good news perché questa è una
grande azienda agricola e non è la sola
ce ne sono tante di grandi e piccole che
incontrò nel mio lavoro in giro per il
mondo che hanno deciso di adottare un
tipo di agricoltura che collabori con il
suolo
l'agricoltura biodinamica pro capite che
tutti questi singoli agricoltori o
queste comunità di agricoltori non
possono davvero fare molto da soli hanno
bisogno della nostra collaborazione
hanno bisogno della nostra
consapevolezza ma ora lo sapete
ora sapete che ognuno di voi quando
decide di mangiare qualcosa beh
collabora in modo molto molto attivo a
quella che è la salute di un suolo
quindi vedete che la memoria del suolo
ci riguarda davvero molto da vicino
perché il suolo
bisogno di noi e solo bisogno di essere
vivo il suolo ha bisogno di sviluppare
la migliore memoria possibile senza se e
senza ma
[Applauso]